vor ein paar jahren habe ich das erste
mal von s p drohen gehört unfassbare
geschwindigkeiten nie dagewesene
aufnahmen und leider auch eine menge
aufwand den man erstmal betreiben muss
um überhaupt in die luft zu kommen eine
menge geld um eine menge tipps
also habe ich das projekt etwas hinten
angestellt und nicht nicht weiter darum
gekümmert bis letzten monat ein
komplettpaket von dj vorgestellt wurde
und ich wusste das will ich lernen viel
spaß mit in sieben tagen rp drohne
[Musik]
ich bin komplett ohne jede ahnung in
dieses projekt rein gestartet und
deswegen habe ich mich erst mal mit
jemandem zusammen getan der wirklich
ahnung hat der mir ein bisschen dazu
erzählen kann ich habe mark dabei den
könntet ihr schon aus meinem auto video
kennen der hat nämlich für diese
wunderbaren aufnahmen im car porn
gesorgt absoluter profi fliegt jetzt wie
lange wie lange bist schon fliegen
ich klicke seit anderthalb jahren gut
anderthalb jahren füllten so man braucht
auch ordentlich zeit um das zu lernen
auf jeden fall das ist eine sehr
langsame kurve und fand also die ich
habe die ersten zwei bestimmt nur im
simulator verbracht dann war ich länger
im simulator was im endeffekt gut tut
weil die kräfte beim ersten mal mal
gucken also ich zumindest ich habe den
großen vorteil dass ich eine fertige
drohne hat für mich gilt nicht noch das
ding zum programmieren zusammenzubauen
was ist dieses gerät was ich benutze
rauskamen absolut muss war sonst ist man
als fwv pilot nicht in die luft bekommen
jetzt mit mir mag aber die basics zu
erklären so dass ich erst mal in die
luft komme und mich hoffentlich auch in
der luft halten kann man sieht hier
schon das ist das setup von marc das ist
mein setup also du brauchst schon
deutlich mehr kamen und dann weg in die
luft zu kommen ja aber es ist alles
irgendwie es geht dann doch ich würde
sagen
du gehst erstmal in die luft mit deinem
gerät wir schauen uns das ganze mal an
und dann gucken wir in die wehr nicht am
ersten tag in irgendeiner weise was
machen kann ja gut dann schickt den lipo
an einer so crazy jetzt ist jetzt das
alles verbunden hier läuft die cam das
ist das womit filme ganz marokko und
hier guck ich eigentlich durch das bild
nach übertragen ok in die brille und das
ist das eigentliche fbw fliegen das
heißt first person dadurch okay wir sind
geehrt
[Musik]
man sieht schon dass dem controller
wahrscheinlich ein bisschen anders
steuer stellt so der der typische magic
drohnen pilot soll mit beiden fingern an
den sticks das gibt ja immer nur ein
bisschen mehr bisschen grün bis mehr
kontrolle dass du wenn du irgendwelche
das kann man über macht halt die sticks
nicht verlierst es hier natürlich nicht
haben sondern keine gallen obstacles wo
man jetzt geil zeigen kann wie fdp
abgeben kann
das potenzial davon auf freiem feld geil
zum üben kann es erstmal nicht crashen
fast keine keine gebäude oder irgendwas
in bahrain sehen kannst und freundin
hast du auch keinen verbindungsabbrüche
mich selber noch jetzt fliege ich nur
line of sight killer
ich glaube ich probier mal mein gerät
kurz abzuschalten und dann
im prinzip hat die drohne drei modi den
neutralen modus in dem die drohne sich
wie eine normale merck fliegt also super
viele assistenzsysteme hat langsam
fliegt und sie quasi unmöglich zu
crashen ist das war der modus mit dem
ich angefangen habe
danach kommt der sport modus deutlich
schnellere geschwindigkeiten deutlich
steiler zu fliegen also schnellere
kurven und so weiter aber nach wie vor
mit ein paar assistenzsystem das ziel
für dieses video ist der komplett
manuelle modus in dem keine
assistenzsysteme in irgendeiner weise
eingreifen indem man rollen fliegen kann
philips fliegen kann und wo man
komplette kontrolle über diese drohne
hat extrem gefährlich und bis zu 150
km/h schnell
ich habe mehr chips als das ich mich
freue die hat sensoren die hat sich dann
von alleine landen kann stoppen
den stop gramm hausherr wenn du halt
normal fließt dann ist also wenn du an
tennis oder irgendwas passiert passiert
und da ist so bin ich mir egal
als übels windig er soll schon knapp
das war sehr das ist noch nicht so wie
ich mir das vorstelle dass er sehr gute
so dicker walter aber ja also ich bin im
neutralen modus und es ist alleine das
ist schon schlimm ich habe noch einiges
vor mir damit das vernünftig
funktioniert wissen wir dass wir machen
den nächsten tagen weiter ich hab noch
wirklich was durch starken wind und
fehlendes fingerspitzengefühl bin ich am
ersten tag nur im neutralen modus
geflogen und habe da erst gemerkt was es
wirklich mit sich bringt dieses ding zu
kontrollieren ich habe vorher nie eine
drohne besessen bin also wirklich bei
absolut null gestartet
und selbst im neutralen modus hatte ich
so meine probleme und ja ich weiß eine
menge leute von euch warten nur auf
rolex trailer videos allerhand mega bock
drauf und ich freue mich auch wieder wir
sind am drehen wir sind am planen aber
das ist nicht das einzige letztes jahr
habe ich drei pilotfolgen von einem
studio format auf diesem kanal
hochgeladen die unfassbar gut an kamen
die super bock gemacht haben und die
jetzt zu einem eigenen kanal werden die
ersten folgen davon mit streamen und mit
leuten von euch drehen wir schon am
samstag also diese woche samstag erster
fünfter dafür brauchen wir noch ein paar
leute wenn ihr lust habt an dem projekt
teilzunehmen in den ersten folgen dabei
zu sein dann checke den link in der
video beschreibung bewerbt euch und dann
könnt ihr teil davon sein
das wird ein eigener kanal da kommen
regelmäßige uploads wir machen jetzt ein
paar test folgen das wird super super
krass ist ein sehr großes investment
wenn ihr mehr dazu sehen wollt ich habe
ein video auf 1 2 kanal dazu gemacht wo
ich ausführlich darüber spreche ich bin
super pump werden eine feste crew und
das wird super geil tag nochmal zwei
drittes mal vierter versuch heute
versuchen nochmal 5 pp selbstexperiment
ist oder des lernprozesses wir sind
mittlerweile nicht mehr in deutschland
ich befinde mich gerade auf madeira und
ich glaube es gibt keinen besseren ort
in europa als madeira wurde zu fliegen
und dabei auch noch vernünftige
aufnahmen zu machen
dafür müsste es aber auch erst mal
funktionieren deswegen starten wir
wieder in dem einfachsten modus und
werden uns wenn es gut läuft dann die
modus so weiter hoch arbeiten man sieht
mit dieser brille zwar sehr
professionell aus aber ich hatte noch
eigentlich keine schwierigkeiten kein
signal mehr
[Musik]
was das sein soll da ist sehr sehr
erfolgreicher tag drohne hat ein
bisschen unter dem letzten landeversuch
gelitten sollte aber glaube ich noch
komplett funktionieren ich bin gespannt
an tag 3 bin ich dann endlich in den
sport modus gewechselt superschnelles
tempo super steilen kurve in die
mittleren modus scheiße dies wirklich so
schnell
[Applaus]
wenn gottes gnaden wollen wir haben
richtig krasse aufnahmen gemacht und so
ging das dann auch an tag 4 5 und 6
weiter versuchen noch mal fünf oder
sechs ich habe den überblick verloren
was ich auf jeden fall weiß ist dass ich
beim letzten mal die aufnahme nicht
gestartet habe das wird mir heute nicht
passieren
wir sind an einer an einem unfassbaren
ort hier auf madeira der nebel steht
hier ganz oben über der gruppe und hier
unten geht's richtung meer
das werdet ihr jetzt gleich auch alles
noch auf der drohne sehen ich hoffe das
funktioniert alles und ich bringe das
denken wieder heil auf dem boden
mittlerweile habe ich aber wirklich
gefühl dafür und fühle mich deutlich
sicherer wenn nochmal auszumerzen
[Musik]
andere welt die wirklichen videos
leider immer noch nicht im komplett
freien modus also jetzt noch mal
deutlich schneller und kann sich noch
mal gut um hier ein bisschen eindruck
von der insel zu bekommen das war
versuch nummer fünf und die nächsten
versuche werde ich dann noch mal in
einem online laden zurück in köln wenn
ich also für ein paar tage in den
simulator gegangen hat eine menge
stunden verbracht und auch da war es am
anfang wirklich sehr schwer für mich zu
kontrollieren aber es ist immer besser
geworden ich weiß nicht wie ich euch
richtig vermitteln kann wie schwer das
ist aber es war wirklich unglaublich so
was habe ich vorher noch nie gemacht so
feine bewegungen die so eine krasse
auswirkungen dann wirklich im reallife
haben oder zu dem zeitpunkt noch im
simulator
es ist unfassbar wirklich also absolute
hochachtung vor allen leuten die
wirklich professionell fpd fliegen und
es schaffen auf mehrere zentimeter an
irgendwelche sich bewegenden objekten
anzufliegen
es ist unglaublich irgendwann muss man
aber wechseln ich hab meinen ganzen mut
zusammengenommen die drohne eingepackt
und bin auf ein leeres feld gefahren
endlich ist es so weit ich konnte die
drohne komplett auf manuell umstellen es
ist nahezu windstill das wetter ist
perfekt und ich bin sehr aufgeregt und
hat bock das ganze jetzt auf komplett
manuell auszuprobieren
ich werde als allererstes ganz normal in
die luft steigen dann in den komplett
manuellen modus wechseln und dann
schauen wir mal ob das ganze
funktioniert komplett erst mal ein
bisschen nach vorne
es ist schon deutlich wackliger das
sieht man ich gehe ein bisschen rum tag
hier meine erste kurve zu fliegen
jetzt probiere ich über die zeit immer
ein bisschen schneller und flüssiger zu
werden hier ist geht tatsächlich aber
ich bin natürlich auch relativ hoch noch
minimalste bewegungen auf dem stick die
das alles kontrollieren ich weiß nicht
ob wir das auf der kamera gerade sät man
merkt dass ich noch super holprig war
ich habe sehr krasse bewegungen gemacht
die die aufnahmen dann quasi verkackt
hätten wenn man jetzt wirklich zu
nehmende aber ich bin im manuellen modus
geflogen und das hat eigentlich ganz gut
funktioniert oder eine kleine
bruchlandung hatten wir erfolgreicher
erster manuela flug aber die drohne ist
an ein paar stellen wirklich kaputt ich
glaube tatsächlich dass sie trotzdem
noch fliegen kann ab jetzt ist es
einfach nur üben üben ich habe so
standard muss gemacht wie steil in die
luft zu fliegen herunterzudrehen und
quasi zu teilen also auf den boden zu
fliegen und kurz vor hochzuziehen
das ganze natürlich auf dem feld damit
ich niemanden verletzen kann läuft läuft
läuft merke dass der einzige weg wie sie
jetzt noch besser werden kann ob singles
und viel training sind nicht mehr auf
dem freien feld sondern durch sachen
durchfliegen ist gar nicht so leicht
sachen zu finden bei denen man keine
leute gefährdet aber dass wir die
aufgabe für die nächsten tage wird heute
ist es endlich soweit ihr könnt es
wahrscheinlich schon im hintergrund
erkennen
ich habe mir einen platz gesucht an
lebens verschiedenster obstacles gibt es
gibt ein haus das auf beiden seiten
offen ist hier werden wir probieren
komplett durch zu fliegen auf der
anderen seite hier gibt es einen
schornstein der so würde ich schätzen 50
meter hoch ist an dem wir probieren
können zu teilen
wir haben eine menge platz hier ist
niemand unterwegs wir gefährden
niemanden da vorne ist eine kleine
brücke hier können uns komplett austoben
ich bin super amt und will direkt in die
luft
wo mir jetzt das allererste mal hier
durch das haus zu fliegen
keine ahnung ob das eine schlaue idee
ist es funktioniert funktioniert
wow die drive sind deutlich schwieriger
als gedacht aber durchs haus das ging
das ganze hat super funktioniert lässt
sich dann leider besuch bekommen haben
sie rausschmeißen der kollege hat mich
sehr freundlich darum gebeten das
gelände doch zu verlassen und ich wusste
ich kann an dem tag jetzt dort nicht
weiterfliegen und ich werde auch in den
nächsten tagen dort nicht weiterfliegen
kann also musste ich mir neues gelände
suchen und das ist wahrscheinlich auch
eine kunst die zum fcb fliegen dazu
gehört einfach plätze zu finden wo sowas
möglich ist und wo man auch wirklich was
zu sehen hat und wo man vernünftig üben
kann also ein freies feld ist cool für
den ersten zweiten dritten tag aber
irgendwann braucht man oft deckels und
muss halt weiter trainieren und genauer
trainieren und dafür braucht man sachen
durch die man hindurch fliegen kann
das war echt schwieriger als gedacht und
ich bin den ganzen tag lang rumgefahren
in köln und habe auf google maps geguckt
wo man das ganze machen könnte und habe
mich für den finalen tag dann im
endeffekt nachdem es bei drei anderen
stellen nicht funktioniert hat für eine
weitere baustelle entschieden
ich habe gesucht google telefoniert volt
für den letzten tagen richtigen länge
haben wollte irgendwie in der skulptur
oder verlassen das haus durch das ich
gut hätte durch fliegen können an dem
ich hätte devon können an dem ich alles
das hätte zeigen können ausprobieren
können was sie jetzt über die woche
gelernt habt das problem ist es ist in
köln einfach nichts zu finden
nichts zu finden wo ich nicht wie
gestern wieder runtergeschmissen werde
in der stadt ist es einfach super
unverantwortlich damit um zu fliegen
natürlich gibt es leute die das machen
und gorilla fliegen wäre wahrscheinlich
auch so einer der nächsten steps aber
das wird hier auf youtube von mir
wahrscheinlich nicht gezeigt und ich
werde das auch nicht machen also ich
hätte gar nichts zu zeigen
nichtsdestotrotz werde ich jetzt gleich
mit vollem speed vollem risiko hier
richtig drüber fetzen und all das
probieren was ich jetzt in den letzten
sieben tagen gelernt
[Musik]
die aus
ja was soll ich dazu sagen
der letzte tag ich wollte alles
riskieren und ich habe alles verkackt
aber wenigstens habe dadurch eine
ziemlich klare antwort kann man den
sieben tagen fpd drohnen fliegen lernen
nein zumindest nicht so dass man sich
immer wieder sicher auf den boden
bekommt so dass die heile bleibt und so
dass man es sich zutrauen könnte
irgendwo zu fliegen wo leute oder
normale gebäude sind sehr eindeutiges
ergebnis ich werde aber weiter fi wie
drohnen fliegen ich werde die reparieren
lassen und ihr werdet weiterhin
einflüsse davon in meinen videos sehen
aber vielleicht nicht in den nächsten
ein zwei videos ich hoffe ich habe das
video gefallen wenn ja dass wir gerne
leichter vergesst nicht den kanal zu
abonnieren damit der keines der videos
verpasst nächste woche kommt endlich
wieder trade up und ich freue mich wenn
ihr euch alle für test ein trakt macht's
gut
daher geklettert und hier ist es offen